وللمزيد مشاهدينا معي في الاستوديو الزميل
عمر حميداوي عمر اهلا ومرحبا بك معنا عمار
العائله من اوكرانيا بدايه دعنا نتحدث عن
رمزيه هذه الزياره التي يقوم بها قام بها
الرئيس الاكرانيا الى مدينه خرسون
ما سمته القوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك وسائل
الاعلام اوكرانيه بالانتصار وتحرير منطقه
الروسي لماذا هناك رمزيه كبيره لهذه
المنطقه لان اا منطقه استراتيجيه وهي تقع
في قباله منطقه همم جزيره القرم التي
تحتلها روسيا او ضمتها روسيا منذ العام
همم 2014 والاكراميون يتحدثون في الايام
الاخيره عن نيتهم لاستعاده حتى هذه همم
الاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014 اذا
ظهور في هذه المنطقه بالنسبه للرئيسكي له
رمزيه من الناحيه همم العسكريه خاصه انه
يؤكد على وصول القوات الاوكرانيه الى مركز
مدينه خرسون ورفع العلم الاوكراني وكذلك
القيام بتكريم بعض الجنود الاوكرانيون بعض
الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين همم خذوا معارك
ضد القوات الروسيه وايضا صرح همم الرئيس
زيننسكي بان همم ما يحدث الان هو انتصار
لكنه في نفس الوقت ارسل رساله من هذا
المكان الى ربما قمه العشرين التي همم
يعني تجري حاليا في بالي بان اوكرانيا
مستعده للحوار من اجل تحرير اراضيها اذا
هي رساله همم محاوله
لتدوين اكثر واعطاء زخم دولي اكثر لاجود
الاوكرانيه في الحرب ضد روسيا فقط للتذكير
هذه تعتبر همم من الناحيه العسكريه
بالنسبه للاوكرانيين انتصار لماذا لانها
المره الثالثه
التي تنسحب فيها القوات الروسيه من مناطق
او مشاريع حربيه ارادت ان تواصل او تنفذها
انسحبت من منطقه كييف ومن سحبت من منطقه
خال كيف والان تنسحب من منطقه خرسون
القوات الروسيه على الجانب الاخر تقول بان
هذا الانسحاب تكتيكي خاصه في هذه المرحله
منطقه خرسون كانت همم قد تكون هدفا للقوات
الاوكرانيه من خلال استهداف احد اهم
السدود في هذه المنطقه واغلاق المنطقه
وبالتالي همم اجبار القوات الروسيه على او
حصر القوات الروسيه في مستنقع واراده
القوات الاوكرانيه بالاستعانه بقوات او
باستعانه بالدعم الغربي لمحاصره القوات
الروسيه لذلك روسيا اتخذت هذا القرار
الصعب لكنه قرار استراتيجي على حد وصفي
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تقريبا وتباتا الاوكرانيه في المنطقه
من اخرصون استعدادا لمكانه يسمى بمعركه
تحرير المدينه من التواجد الروسيه
ولهذا السبب كان مفاجاه بالنسبه للعديد من
المراقبين وحتى نحن الذين
يعني نتنقل في هذه المنطقه همم مع القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تنتشر وتستعد لمعركه
طويله كانوا يعتقدون بانها ستكون هناك
معركه شتويه لتحرير منطقه خرسون خاصه وان
القوات الروسيه بحسب الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه كانت قد نشرت قوات من المارينز
عفوا من البحريه الروسيه وكذلك قوات من
الكوماندو في وسط مدينه خرسون وكذلك قامت
بافراغ اكثر من 15 كيلو مترا من الجانب
الشرقي لمدينه همم خلصنا من السكان تحضيره
لما يعرف في المعركه الشتويه اذا قرار
المفاجاه لكن الذين همم يعني الذي
لاحظناها ايضا هو صلاه
همم القوات الاوكرانيه التي كانت تقاتل
بمبدا المجموعات او او الجيغيه الحرب
الصغيره في مناطق محدده كانت تعتمد على
المدفعيه المتنقله وكذلك فرق الدبابه التي
تقترب من الخطوط الدفاعيه الروسيه وتقوم
بمهاجمه القوات الروسيه وهو ما يسمى
بالعرف العسكري محاوله اشغال العدو وكذلك
الاستمرار في الضغط عليه ربما هذا الضغط
وهذه الجهود التي استمرت على مدى شهرين
دفعت الروس الى هذا الانسحاب لكن في ذلك
الوقت همم كان همم غير متوقع ان يكون هذا
الانسحاب لكن الان دخلت القوات الاوكرانيه
ولا ننسى بان القوات الروسيه لا زالت
منتشره في اجانب الايسر من نهر النيبر وهو
همم منطقه من منطقه مقابل